Some other definitions we want to, to pull from during this lesson are, one from
Dwayne Perry and Alex Wolf, that involves elements, forms and rationale.
Rationale being the set of dis, the, the decisions and
reasons for making them, that the architects have agreed on.
Obviously, architecture involves the fundamental organization,
components and relationships.
This comes from the IEEE definition.
Another element from Verhoff is the determination of what
makes up the components here based upon
hiding away those things which are hardest to change.
That's a little bit different way of thinking about a system.
But if you imagine what the system is going to be
like several years after its initial release, it's going to change.
And those changes have the potential of breaking the system in unexpected ways.
So by hiding away those tough decisions
we can help reduce the overall maintenance cost downstream.
And then for the rest of this lesson, we're going to be guided by the Garlan and
Shaw paper which is listed on the class resource page, and they talk about
architecture in terms of its components, its connectors, and its configurations.
What do they mean by these three terms?
Well, a component is a computational or a data element, plus its interfaces,
which they call ports, interfaces to the rest of the system.
The interfaces express what the component requires or
needs from the rest of the system, and what it provides.
Recall from the UML component diagrams,
this is exactly what the interfaces, represent.
A connector is a, essentially a communication protocol among components,
although it may have code associated with it for
enforcing that particular protocol.
It is its, its major element of defining the character is that protocol.
And then configuration is how you put those pieces together.
You plug a connector into a component.
You plug the other end of the connector into another component if it's a binary
connector, and the ports then can talk to each other using the connector.
That overall topology for the pieces is called a configuration.